Tracks laden Spaß laden jeden Tag um diese Uhrzeit
das witzige ist ja du bist ja noch in frankfurt so der sauberste in frankreich ich habe ich habe
einen ping teilweise von acht oder so also wenn wir das beste spiel brauchen schild
das war schon eine schöne erinnerung tranks laden scheiß laden mann spaß telekom
das stream wird natürlich schon abgekackt
Tracks laden ey ich bin so stinkig auf die telekom
was machen die da hinten irgendwie weg sind aber viel zu spät ich komme so schnell
wie es geht wieder ihr macht das
oh cool ich habe zweimal shift und zweimal links klick gedrückt
über mir über mir etwas
bei mir ruckelt schon wieder alles
oh mann tracks telekom verfick das scheiß laden ey
dass ich sowas überhaupt provider nennen darf
können sich fail weiter oder so nennen
fack ey tracks laden ich bin so stinkig auf den scheiß saft laden ey
das ist der wahnsinn
mann chat geht übrigens noch nicht mal da ist das ist einfach rippt der chat
ich konnte nichts dagegen machen jetzt hast ja selbst tolle zeugs
so jetzt geht wenigstens der chat wieder schreibt mal bitte was im chat leute
dass ich sehe was wieder funktioniert so ein scheiß laden die telekom ey jeden tag
um diese uhrzeit so sagen wir so 1730 bis 19 uhr gibt es einfach mal dsl
synchronisierung verloren ich meine was machen die denn aber nein wir wollen ja
nichts aber da mach ich mute mich mal da kann ich mir ein bisschen im stream
auslassen aber es ist es ist ja nicht so dass man jetzt in zukunft dass man
ausbauen würde gescheit dass man sagt hey ein paar land ein paar jahre ist das
in deutschland alles toll es wird nur irgendwelche scheiße erzählt so nach dem
motto bis 2010 haben wir es oh haben wir nicht bis 2012 haben wir es oh haben wir
nicht bis 2015 haben wir es oh haben wir nicht aber bis 2018 haben wir es ganz
bestimmt und dreimal dürft ihr raten oh haben wir da natürlich auch nicht
deswegen bauen wir lieber unseren alten scheiß weiter aus anstatt mal neue
ordentliche infrastruktur zu verlegen das ist das ist internet deutschland provider
so ein sausch so ein verfickter trecks mir fällt das nichts mehr ein ohne dass ich
jetzt irgendwelche leute über das beleidigen muss
ja das ist ja nicht nur das ist ja nicht nur in telekom beziehungsweise halt so
internet und so was infrastruktur alles was die bahn schienen sind übelst im arsch
in deutschland straßentechnisch geht auch immer mehr kaputt
kommunikations infrastruktur auch für ein arsch was ich letztens gelesen habe im
internet quasi quasi wasserversorgung sonst was kackt auch an jeder ecke ab aber
was wir können wir können uns geil finden aus welchen gründen auch immer
und wir können uns einreden so nach dem motto wir haben ja so viel geld sind wir
reich und wir sind so geil aber wir bauen die nötigen sachen nicht aus dabei sind
wir gar nicht reich zumindest nicht so im durchschnitt wenn man sich das mal
anguckt klar wir haben viele leute die sau viel geld haben aber im durchschnitt
sind wir in deutschland jetzt auch im vergleich zu anderen ländern können
schwimmen wir jetzt auch nicht alle in gold oder so
ist halt echt lächerlich internetinfrastruktur das noch schlimmer
guckt euch das mal an mobil mobilfunk dass die haben es ja bis heute nicht
gescheit geschafft dass es mal einen ordentlichen mobilfunk tarif gibt mit
ordentlichen datenvolumen der dem jahr 2017 angemessen ist klar es wird besser
mittlerweile aber es ist immer noch der witz bis letztes jahr nein bis dieses
jahr bis dieses jahr gab es gab es kaum tarife die telekom hat dann angefangen
mit ihrem 200 200 euro tarif oder was dieser scheiß gekostet hat ja uns auch
ins hirn geschissen so nach dem motto unlimited und wir tun auch so als wäre
es wirklich unlimited aber ansonsten mobil tarife führen arsch in deutschland
die schweiz gut die schweiz hat vielleicht auch ein bisschen von der
größe einfach und sonst was aber wir könnten das ja auch zumal wir uns ja
immer so geil finden und uns einreden sind wir technologisch so geil ja gut was
wir können wir können u-boote bauen das bringt uns jetzt allerdings auch nicht
wirklich was bist du schon mal von frankfurter mei nach gießen gefahren
nein ich bin aber schon von frankfurter mei nach dresden gefahren das ist die
kaputteste fixstrecke die es überhaupt gibt in deutschland da fährst du im ic
und düst mit mit 40 30 40 km herum weil die strecke so im arsch ist ja hier genau
das gleiche ich finde es auch da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht es ist lächerlich
es ist absurd es ist einfach als videos ist absolut lächerlich dass man für hd
fernseher was bezahlen soll ja ich weiß für öffentlich rechtliche muss man
nichts bezahlen aber was ist das für was ist das eigentlich welches krank
gehirn hat sich diese dm scheiße und diese verschlüsselungskacke fürs
fernseher ausgedacht wenn ich mir jetzt angucken dass du schon gebühren bezahlen
muss für dvb t2 du sollst wird für einen der beschissensten übertragungsarten
und empfangen sollst du noch geld bezahlen oder was
mal davon abgesehen ich gucke kein fernseher wenn ich was gucke gucke ich mir das
auf amazon an oder auf netflix an oder auf was weiß ich irgendwo im internet
was das gibt wie viel habe ich eigentlich verloren für diese von der telekom
gesponserten
geht so
so als heißt wieder ein bisschen abgeregt
die da sind das problem dieser kacke an
so wäre eigentlich das richtige logo für die das ist das ist eigentlich das
richtige logo
das war jetzt absolut easy runde ja gegen irgendwelche komischen goldtypen auch
noch drinnen und was ist flieg raus da braucht diese direkt fritzbox auch so
ewig um sich wieder zu verbinden
bin telekom geschäftskundentechniker ist klar
falls du nicht dabei was das problem falls das wirklich stimmt liegt daran
dass ich immer zwischen 17 uhr 30 und 19 uhr fast jeden tag es ist auch egal ob
wochentag oder wochenende ist der meinung mein dsl die synchronisierung
also halt die verbindung zu verlieren sie ist dann auch schön im modem lock
drinnen dsl ich müsste jetzt mal nachgucken irgendwie dsl synchronisierung
verloren bla sonst was verbinden verbindet sich neu dauert halt drei vier
minuten was halt genau reicht dass man in dem fall jetzt hier eine runde
verliert oder halt das stream abkackt sich nicht reconnecten kann ordentlich
ansonsten habe ich keine großartigen probleme kein packet loss oder sonst was
gar nichts eigentlich ist alles gut außer immer zwischen 17 uhr 30 und 19 uhr
wo es fast fast jeden tag abkackt jetzt ist so wenn es sogar schon bei deiner
leitung so ist und du telekom geschäftskundentechniker bist was soll ich
dann erwachen ich habe mir ich habe eine fritzbox 4000 die kleinste da
7.430 oder irgendwie sowas also die kleinste dies vor weib anschlüsse gibt
habe ich mir gekauft die die nur 100 mbit interfaces hat im jahr 2000 fast 18
lull ist mir erst nachdem ich mir die fritzbox gekauft habe aufgefallen dass
sie nur 100 mbit interfaces hat ich meine es ist schlimm ich habe eh nur vdsl 100
aber trotzdem irgendwie auch ein bisschen leicht lächerlich
übrigens das erste mal dass ich heute skirmast wurde fällt mir gerade so ein
nicht weil die telekom hat mich skirmast der lieferdienst wo ich mittagessen
bestellt haben hat mich auch übelst gescampt ich habe bestellt moment ich sage
euch das jetzt mal ich muss es gerade mal rausholen
sagt es euch jetzt mal moment wb ich bin auch gleich wieder am start
gleich bin klar wieder da so also ich habe heute bestellt box box 5 habe ich
bestellt box 5 ist drin
nein habe ich nicht hier box 6 habe ich 6 habe ich bestellt box 6 ist drin ein
double crunchy burger ein chicken zisler burger 6 hot wings zwei kraut salat
dann stimmt ja überhaupt nicht was sie geliefert haben
zumindest was ich gekriegt habe am ende ist ein komischer chicken burger wo ein
belag gefehlt hat den als ein burger den zweite burger war der komplett falsche
dann kam sie eine stunde 45 minuten gebraucht zum liefern und als zweite
salat hat gefehlt das war das war skirmast pur
ok so bin ready ja ich lade dich ein und dann gehe ich mal ganz schnell noch mal
aufs klo gleich wieder da zwei minuten
ok
jetzt habe ich mich abgeregt jetzt kann es weitergehen
sollst du aufdrücken ja was was sind das aber auch schon wieder für
wochenei das glaubst du nicht ich dachte instant game haben wir nicht
50 verloren 50 na gut wir haben gegen silber platte silber und gold verloren
gerade 50 sie sind 3333 jetzt 3283 50 50 sr telekom danke telekom super
sonst werden wir winning streak und werden wahrscheinlich in drei games
master gewesen oder so lohnt lässt sich von jakt hochkarriere ja easy easy
klapp wir haben gehen aber ich weiß auch nicht irgendwie dieser ganze monat ist
schon richtig verfugt technisch einfach nur problem wir haben die mercy
jetzt noch ein bisschen was tankmäßiges kriegen achso wusstest du das schreibt
er im chat wenn man wenn man disconnected länger als zwei minuten
kriegt man aus automatisch 50 punkte sr egal ob win oder lose das ist aber sehr
nett dass es sehr entgegenkommt für alle telekom kunden
wenn du bann kriegst dann müssen die rechnungen die telekom für den account
schlaut ich wusste jetzt leider noch ein account holen was ich gerade bin
das wäre doch mal was für twitter das wäre nice ja machst du hier so ein
screenshot wie du rausfliegst oder was dass ich was machst du ein bild dazu
schickst das hin junge anna ist echt hot
hotes krill
ich flayn nachher mal ein bisschen telekom hilft oft bitter an da sind zwar
richtig arme säcke nach die können auch überhaupt nichts machen aber die
kümmern sich drum das stimmt tatsächlich also die machen
wenigstens was tippen man hook haben kommten
Oben ist, oben ist ein Reaper
Harambe!
Ey, wir müssen auf den Spot
So, wenigstens einmal guter Push hier direkt durch
Easy Win
Obbei, ob Easy Win zeigt sich am zweiten, die haben ne Sch...
Na doch, doch, ich hab mich verkocht bei den Gegnern
Dachte die hätten nur Moira als Support
Ja, im Prinzip haben sie das ja auch
Weil die Anna von denen macht Damage
Die scheiß Kugel, man!
Reaper hinten
Reaper, ja, Reaper hinten
Nice, Reaper ist weg
Oh, oh
Der ist long
Warum lebt der noch?
Schnub
Die ist noch hinten drinnen, die Tracer
Okay, die ist noch hinten drinnen
Ja, an der Genauigkeit muss ich echt noch arbeiten mit dem
Im Nahkampf wieder die Gegner gescheit zu treffen
Veraim ich, veraim ich noch richtig
Ich hab dir gerade das Pixel Spray am Ende der Runde freigeschaltet
Was, was?
Das Pixel Spray
Es gibt...
Ach, gibt es? Du meinst, wenn du das Achievement gepackt hast?
Ja, ich hab das, ich hab das
Ich hab das, ich hab das
Ich hab das
Du meinst, wenn du das Achievement gepackt hast?
Jaja, und das am Ende der Runde, dass das da immer noch zählt, das ist der Wahnsinn
Was ist, was ist das für ein Achievement?
Also was muss man dafür machen?
Gute Frage, ich...
Sieht man das denn nicht? Kann man das nicht...
Natürlich vor der irgendwie Flashbang...
Keine Ahnung, irgendwas mit der Flashbang
Also wollen die mich alleine dpsen lassen?
So, naja
Ich kann ja wesentlich Damage machen
Wir könnten, wir könnten Soldier noch spielen
Wobei, komm, wir haben noch ne Sombra dabei, das geht, das geht
Das passt
Geht's bald, man
Geht's bald
Ich find das halt immer so scheiße, wenn die Sombra dann reingeht zum EMP machen und so
Und dann musst du vorlaufen und bis du immer da bist, weil du keine Usche dabei hast
Bäh
Hast du eigentlich Mario Odyssey auf der Switch gespielt, Max?
Ja, hab ich
Hab ich
Die TF, gehen die, gehen die rechts, kann das sein? Ich geh schon mal rechts rüber
Also noch machen sie gerade
Ich bleib mal rechts mit unserer Symmetra
Irgendeiner von uns springt vorne rum
Der Rolltalk steht rechts um die Ecke
Die machen gar nichts gerade
Sombra overextendert übertrieben
Er wurde gehansehlt
Rolltalk ist da
Hanjo, ah ne Genji
Aber auch ein Hanso
Die haben Team bis Todes
Haben die auch noch Symmetra? Ne, das war ein Reflekt
Kann das sein, dass die Hardcore reintilten, die Gegner?
Ich bin verrückt, bei der Reinhardt nicht das
Der Hanjo
Keiner da
Als der Old aller Zeiten
Overextendert des Todes
Das war über, wir haben einen Tele
Für verleitetes Scheiße zu machen
Ach Hanso
Hanjo
Echt jetzt? Der hat den Flashbang durch den Schild geworfen nach meiner Flash
Während er gesandt war
Rechts rechts rechts rechts
Flaming as fuck
Hanso musst du Teebeuteln
Komm wir gehen Hanso Teebeuteln, weil er da reinkommt
Den holen wir, ah ne lasst euch doch nicht hauen
Geteebeutelt
Bling bling bling
Und nochmal der Disrespect-Fan
Das Play-off der Game war schon traurig
Ja jetzt bin ich 27 Punkte vor dir
Nach der Runde gehe ich erstmal was futtern
Schon wieder
Was schon wieder
Hast du vorhin erst
Ja um eins oder so
Wahnsinn ey ich hab den ganzen Tag noch nichts gefilmt
Wir sind ja schon wieder
Na gut Abtime sieht man jetzt nicht
Ich glaub ich schon 4 Stunden oder so wieder am Start
Ja könnte hinkommen
Ja 3 Stunden 9
Vor 3 Stunden 9 haben wir angefangen
Der andere ist auch schon wieder eine halbe Stunde
Wir sind 4 Stunden an jetzt
Vorher haben wir auch noch ein bisschen gelabert
Definitiv
Über 4 Stunden
Also ich dachte wir zählen jetzt noch durch bis wir im Master sind
Mal gucken mal gucken wie es läuft
Komm mal wir haben schon den ersten Master
Der arme Teufel wird sich denken wo bin ich da nur gelandet
Wahrscheinlich
Ah nee ist ein 3er Stack selber schuld
Sieht nicht so aus als hätten wir einen guten Tank
Falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab Leute im Chat dann schreibts nochmal
Oh gar kein mehr
Sagen wir ein Banzo
Ähm
Naja
Mal gucken
71% Winrate auf Mac 3
Du
Ja
Was
Habst du aus dem Dreck gezogen
Die 28% da
Hatte ich 28% echt auf dem Account
Ich hab den nie gespielt
Also anscheinend doch mal
Ich lass sie laufen
Mercy Mercy hinten drinnen
Fast tot
Hast du viel für die fiesi Zwischenprüfung gelernt
Oh nee
Ich hab gerade Heal Boost gemacht
Ich kann dich abholen
Sag wenn du gespawnt bist
Bin gespawnt aber
Ne
Die machen das schon
Das schaut nicht danach aus
Oh
Arcade in die Fresse
Ey die Anna schon wieder so ein Supporter der nicht heilt
Steht halt neben mir und heilt mich macht lieber Damage
Regrub
Regrub Leute
Oben links
Ja
Ich hab Ulti
Wo ich wurde geregt
Oh jetzt geht er ab jetzt geht er steil hier
Nee leider nicht
Arc
Na gut dann warte ich mal
Ich hoffe die sterben nicht bis wir vorne sind
Pass mal links auf Micron drauf wenn wir durchkommen
Wow war das knapp
Ich wurde runtergekickt fast fast
Rechts kommt ein Warthog
Oh
Piss dich Fahrer
Ach Eiskreuter ok
Na das ist das ist gar nicht so schlecht
Regrub
Leute im Fight gewinnen dann haben wir es doch fast
Einfach nicht Staggern Leute einfach Regrub
Ach wir haben übrigens keine Anna mehr wir haben jetzt eine Moira
War wahrscheinlich zu gut die kommt
Ich speedboost uns da jetzt rein
Ja super ich will flanken auf einmal flanken also
Oh ich hab ihn gekickt
Da kannst du nichts machen jetzt
Ja das stimmt die Physi Prüfung ist nicht schwer
Nein nein
So wird das geben
Ich glaub da müssen die Huge Mercy Plays ran oder
Na ja wahrscheinlich
Ich glaub da müssen Huge Mercy Plays jetzt
Hatten die was für Anti Air
Sonst können wir Fahrer Mercy spielen
Nee hatten sie nicht
Dann bleibst halt nur an mir dran
Bleib an dir kleben
Ich strahle dich an
Wir sollen halt mal ordentliche Heroes picken oder sowas keine Ahnung
Die Moira kann ja auch ein bisschen was heilen da vorne
Komm wir haben viel Nahkampf
Die spielt 100% Moira weil sie Damage machen will ich sag sie
Oh fuck fuck fuck der Winston ist an mir
Ich muss mal kurz den Typ heilen bei uns und hier einen retten
So einfach kann das sein
Bis in den Spawn
Siehst du mal nur Mercy dabei und schon machst du einen Spawn Rape
Vielleicht sollten wir es aber nicht unbedingt übertreiben
Kommst du mit
Ich laufe dir hinterher
Hinter dir hinterher
Ja ich kam
Vielleicht gehen wir noch ein bisschen gestalt
Hab gleich wieder Ulti
Hinter dir
Ich check das nicht wie man das mit der Mercy richtig macht
Wie man das Speed kriegt
Was ist denn das denn
Ja Point
Oh ich hab Ult an
Wir müssen jetzt drauf
Ja das bringt nix
McQueen kann ich jetzt auch nicht picken
Weil der Paladin hat
Den hätte ich ein bisschen später machen müssen die Ulti war bescheuert viel zu viel Zeit vergeudet mit der Ulti vorm Tor
Ich bin gleich da
Ich muss mal ich bin bald nicht bei dir
Links und rechts
Der ist unter uns
Okay jetzt muss er echt schnell sein
Jetzt muss er echt schnell sein
Ne da kann ich mal contesten oder
Da bin ich da
Und vorbei
Fuck
Da sieht man halt meine Kack Mercy Plays wie kacke das eigentlich ist
Da geht ne geht nix mehr
Mal sagen wenn der Genji noch dein Ulti macht
Ich würde gern mit Anna besser werden hast du irgendwelche Tipps
Ja spiel ich zieh mal raus
Der einzige Grund warum ich Mercy spiele ist ja weil Mercy so OP ist nicht weil ich es gut kann oder mit der Held Spaß macht
Weil du ohne Mercy quasi kaum noch was gewinnen kannst
Anna kann man als zweiten Heiler oder so spielen
Oder man kann Anna auch Solo Heal spielen das funktioniert allerdings gerade ist schwierig
Anna selbst ist eigentlich das wichtigste dass du deine Heals triffst
Sowohl aus der Hüfte auch als auch im Scope
Das ist erstmal das allerwichtigste bei Anna du musst deine Heals treffen
Danach musst du dir angucken wo du deine Granate am besten drauf wirfst
Nicht immer sind die eigenen Teammates das beste Ziel am besten ist wenn du eigene Teammates plus Gegner treffen kannst
Wenn du einen Roadhog hast der beispielsweise einen gegnerischen Reinhardt hookt
Dann wirfst du noch während er herangezogen wird mit dem Hook wirfst du direkt eine Granate auf deinen Roadhog drauf
Dass der Reinhardt dann auch noch lila wird
Dann kann keiner mehr den Reinhardt retten
Und die hohe Kunst bei Anna ist Liebdarts halbwegs treffen
Wobei man wenn man sich auf große Targets konzentriert wie im Nahkampf den Reinhardt durch Schild laufen reingehen und sowas
Du kannst ja durch das Reinhardt Schild durchlaufen und quasi Shift dabei drücken
Und dann schießt du dem Reinhardt irgendwo hin weil das ist ein massiv fettes Ding vor deiner Nase
Den Sleep Dart an ihn dran was sehr hilfreich ist
Oder halt auch ein Roadhog ein Roadhog der ultet beispielsweise ist auch ein super Sleep Dart Target
Muss man sich ein bisschen rantasten
Ich könnte eigentlich Mercy spielen wo wir gerade dabei sind
Spiel mal ne Runde Mercy wenn wir jemanden im Stream haben der sich Mercy ein bisschen angucken will
Zwar schon ein bisschen eingerostet
Du sprichst von Mercy spielen aber bist auf Anna
Hab ich Mercy gesagt? Ich mein Anna
Hab ich die ganze Zeit Mercy gesagt?
Wenn ich Mercy sag liegt es daran dass mich der Held mittlerweile so krass verwirrt hat dass ich überhaupt nicht mehr durchblicke
Ich mein Anna mit der ganzen Sleep Dart Geschichte natürlich
Sehst du mal wie mein blown brainfuck das ganze schon ist
Ich glaube ich spiele lieber irgendeinen Tank
Komm her Scheiß drauf
Wir brauchen einen Tank
Ich mein der Hanzo könnte ja auch mal irgendwas anderes spielen
Genji hat er noch Genji hat er noch im Angebot
Der hat mehr rank play time als ich
Der keilt uns jetzt
Links ist ein Warthog im Hotel
Ok wir gehen rechts rum
Hallo Hallo Hallo
Da sieht man da ist halt ein Heal zu wenig wenn du so viel Damage frisst
Jetzt gibt es Hanzo Main sogar in Hortz was in Hortz gibt es Hanzo
Kommt er
Ich hab 3 HP die ganze Zeit
Geht ran
Nein ich hatte keinen Charge da Fuh ich wollte Counter Chargen
Fuck
Das hab ich gerade nicht verstanden warum sind wir langsamer im Respawn als die Gegner
Weiß nicht
Ah das war scheiße ich wollte den Counter Chargen
Jetzt GGen sie schon wir haben wieder die Besten dabei Besten der Besten der Besten noch 2 Minuten 30
Aber GG
Rechts rum Warthog
Ich hab gleich Shatter
Gehen wir mal Hotel
Was ich war hinterm Auto
Bäm
Nichts gemacht aber gewonnen so ist das schön
Gleich gibt es Huge Slam
Nein Nein
Ich bin auf dem Paylord als einziger warte mal bis es losfährt
Das wäre sehr nice
Huge
Für 60 Slam naja ganz so über 3 muss man es nicht
Auf die Style Punkte hebe ich mir dann für die Master Plus Spiele auf
Und Sleep
Ich push mal mit unserer Mercy oder oder oder Murky Murky muss man ja sagen
Hätten wir noch einen am Paylord wären wir schon dran
Rechts
Das war recht ich dachte erst wir werden geregt
Kleiner wieder Shatter
Murky liegt Murky liegt Schild um Reinhard Reinhard ich war viel Reinhard
Selbst da mir macht Murky auch kein Spaß
Jetzt First Pwn Hold
Die Zeit war ziemlich gut
Am Anfang haben wir ein bisschen gebraucht was geil war dass der Typ schon GG tat im Chat
Wir haben zwei Angriffe gemacht sind geweibt der Typ ist GG Leute jetzt ist abgelaufen
GG und jetzt haben wir in drei Minuten durch gepusht von GG zu drei Minuten Zeit übrig
Ich mag Mercy ich bin noch nicht gut genug ach doch das geht
Guck mal sogar ich kann Mercy spielen das heißt schon was
Ich habe nie Mercy gespielt
Gestern oder so im Stream die ersten paar Runden
Und nicht dass ich wirklich irgendwie gut spielen würde oder so aber es hat trotzdem massiv
Impact weil Mercy einfach so scheiß OP ist
Du kannst für dein Team viel machen
Auch ohne wirklich jetzt so extrem abzugehen
Und mit der Zeit kriegt man es ja raus
Kannst du gucken ob die den Velo haben
Ja da steht schon irgendwas oben rum irgendwas damage geboosted das steht da oben rum
Bestimmt ein Hanzo ich wollte gerade sagen bestimmt ein Hanzo
Die Anna wird jetzt geregt die da vorne allein steht
Mercy wo rennst du hin
Wieder wieder wieder wieder
Und Genji geht links rum Genji geht links rum
Geben wir ein Stückchen Schild weg
WTF
Wieder wieder um links um links um links Anna um links
Wir übertreiben es mal nicht
50% erst für Shatter
Der charge mich jetzt
Macht er nicht macht er nicht
Ich komme auch mal ein Stückchen vor zu euch
Oh schöner Fire Strike Raffe
Discord off los werden
Schön Saria feeden
Wie es sich das gehört
Shatter gleich da 10%
Ok Shatter da
Kommt zurück Leute kommt zurück
Kommt zurück
Die wollen nicht zurück die haben keinen Bock
Denken sie sich die Ohne hoch
Sneaky Reinhard kommt jetzt
Das war keine so gute Idee mit Sneaky Reinhard
Rechtes Schild von ihm der hat Shatter
Oh jutsch
Sollte er noch
Jutsch Shatter den können wir mal klippen der war nice
Der war echt er da waren 5 Leute drin
Als hat es richtig zerrissen
Ja nur schade wegen der Zen Ulti
Aber ich habe wieder Shatter passt
Achso 6 gegen 5
Wann ist denn der Typ raus
Ja Soldier perfekt
Kommt mal zurück Leute wir müssen es doch nicht provozieren jetzt
Haha Gengu
Oh oh oh oh Yolo Charge Yolo Charge help
Ist wieder da
Der Docs geht ab
Ok wir sollten jetzt ein Stückchen zurück
Oder direkt Choke Point eins von beiden
Zurück Schild geht kaputt
Haha
Gleich wieder Shatter am Start
Leute overextendet doch nicht so Alter
Das war ja nichts
Voll gechoked wieder hier
Hahaha hast du es gesehen
Beste Ult vom Junkrat beste Ult
Kommt jetzt können wir noch mal kontesten
Jaja
Jetzt nicht mehr
Doch oh fuck
Aber die können noch ein paar Ults verbrennen
Ganz schlimm die können ruhig noch ein paar Ults verbrennen
Sniperboy ja ich auch
So jetzt ordentlich regroupen und vipen
Shatter 60%
Also kenn ich jetzt über euch
Muss weg
Shatter 94%
Ich brauche Heal Heal
Oh das war jetzt Overkill das war Overkill wir brauchen noch was für den nächsten Fight
Ich habe was aber dann brauche ich mehr Protection
Kannst hinter mir rein
Gut dass er heilen sich seinen Schild jetzt schon darum machen wir es
Ja perfekt
Genau so muss das sein
Mines hat nur noch 1000
50 Shatter
Hammer Action
So jetzt nicht leben
Und Play
To Plates
Jetzt kommt er hier jetzt kommt er
Ich wollte mich mal selbst weil ich meine Reihenhand Face so nice fand
Ich muss sagen wenn man das eine Weile spielt man kriegt es irgendwann so irgendwann merkst du dass du es so ein bisschen gecheckt hast weißt du
Am Anfang kommst du dir total überfordert vor mit einem neuen Helter
Scheiß was mache ich jetzt was mache ich jetzt links rechts keine Ahnung
Und irgendwann hat man so den Flow dann so langsam aber sicher raus
So ich habe meine 50 Punkte noch nicht wieder aufgeholt
Noch fehlen noch 15
164 brauchen wir noch dann sind wir Master
Ja fast
Ich brauche 180 ungefähr soll ich Q
Und anpassen
Hat er schon was mit der Altimate gekillt
Du meinst unser Soldier der Soldier ging aber krass ab
Also der Docs den wir hatten der war gut
Du meinst diese eine Altimate die er gesetzt hat die gut war
Er hat in der in der Street
Also direkt nach dem ersten Chalk Point vom ersten Punkt
Da hat er sechs Leute fünf sechs Leute hat er gehauen
Na gut mit Tagweise wenn alle no sind aber ey
Immerhin ja ich meine er macht das wofür er da ist
Ebenworten
Patrick was muss ich aufrufen zum Battlefield 3 zocken ja
Wenn der Battlefield 3 auf meinem Server zocken wollte
Ausrufezeichen Server
Puma Anna ist ist derjenige noch da der Anna sehen wollte
Dann spiele ich meine Runde Anna
Aber ich muss wahrscheinlich wieder Tank spielen
Was hat denn der Puma sonst
Genji
Okay ich sehe schon ich muss ich muss Mercy in Reinhardt spielen
Du kannst immerhin später kein DPS
Das ist schon mal was ja
Ich auch mit Bastion auf den
Oder mit Torb attack Torb auf den K aufs K drauf
Probieren wir es mal mit Bastion
Genji dabei
Hier oben raus
Klingt wie die Vibration von einem iPhone
Hast du auch schöne Bastion Sounds
Du du du du du du du du du du
Ich komme hier nicht hoch
Das ist das
Ich bin auf der Masi Masi fast tot
Ja ich brauche dann dein Schild bei mir
Setz drauf
Du musst ein bisschen Platz machen ich sehe nichts
Auch noch Sonderwünsche das
Wo stelle ich mich
Alter wo stelle ich mich denn hier am besten hin
Links in Nordhock links in Nordhock
Ich glaube du musst ein bisschen weiter hinter
Ich bleib drauf stehen und pushe
Ich stehe oben drauf kannst du
Ja wenn ich hochkomme
Ich spring mal vor dir geht auch oder
Nachladen
Schatten
Siehst du was
Ja
Wenn ich auf dem hohen Teil
Ich stelle mich mal an die Wand
Bastion Strats bester
Schatten
Richtig
War der beste Schatten aller Zeiten
Das war richtig der Drecks Schatten
Ich dachte
Schatten hast du mal die ultende Mäurer
Und du treffst die nicht mal
Ich habe gerade die beschissenste Nano Dings bekommen
Die es gegeben hätte können
Hast du Tank gezogen
Gerade wo die D.Va Ulti kam
Kriege ich nano
Soll ich mit dir gehen
Nein
Ihr müsst mit der Druck machen
Pushen
Ich stehe in der Falle
Leute kommt vor
Mercy ist down
Freck gibt 6 HP
Nein
Man braucht mit Reinhardt eine höhere Sense
Du musst quasi einmal swingen
Und 360 machen können
Dann ist gut
Stellst du dich auf
Die Motorhaube am besten
Da oben
Ich schau links in den Tire
Kann mich die Mercy fressen
Gut
Helfe, Helfe, Helfe
Reinhardt
Ist schon wieder so ein Panic Nano bekommen
Ich lauf mal vor dir wenn es hier hoch geht
Schild hoch
Hammer Time
Das ging noch zackig
Das ging noch gut
Bastion Strats haben sie überrascht
Aber ich glaube wenn wir jetzt in Defense wieder Bastion Strats machen ist das zu predictable weißt du
Wir sollten die Hanzo Torp Strats machen
Ich bin schon dabei
Es gibt keine Hanzo Torp Strats
Wir machen die Hanzo Orissa Strats
Wobei mit Orissa verrecke ich immer
Ich bin lieber Reinhardt ein bisschen mobiler
Wir haben zwei richtig fette Heiler das müsste eigentlich gehen
Meine Fire Strikes
Sobald dein Schild down ist
Du kommst einfach nicht mehr weg
Du hast keinen Knockback, keine gar nichts, bloß diese scheiß Kugeln
Und dann bist du auch noch mega langsam beim Angreifen
Jetzt im Chat schon über meine Huge Fire Strikes und Shadows lustig gemacht
Was haben wir da? Widow, Hanna, Sen, Genji
Okay sieht gut aus, können wir schon farmen
Hatten die einen Fahrer oder sowas? Widow haben sie
Reinhardt und ein Roadhog
Geht down, geht down
Wir müssen runter
Ich geh runter
Hanzo ist am Start
Harambe
Danke, ich gleich dabei
Ich lad mal Schild
Shadow 20
Der kommt nicht
Der pullt
Ich hab kaum noch Schild, fast down
Pass auf, ich muss geheelt werden
Haha, jebaited hat sie mich
Leute, lasst mal nicht so sehr overextenden, kommt mal zurück
Das war viel zu weit overextended
Hast du down? Wie hast du, WTF, was hast du mit denen gerade angestellt?
Massakriert, massakriert
Die sind ja, komm, WTF, meine Lautsprecher ist ausgefallen am Headset jetzt
Es war zu viel, zu viel Ownage war das
Reingehustet ins Mikro, jetzt geht er wieder
Wo sind die Farrows?
Rechts, rechts
Ist wieder Main
Oh nein, ich hab's nicht mehr so gemeint, Farrows tut mir leid
Die kommen oben rechts
Mercy ist gerekt
Oh, jebaited
Hardcore, jebaited
Das war richtig dumm, hätt ich mir aufheben müssen
Oh fuck, das war mein Fail, ich dachte, komm, haust du den scheiß Harambe weg, aber nein
Das war mein Fail, ja, das war echt mein Fail, ich war so im Hammerrausch irgendwie
Aber wir können doch mal contesten
Nee, kommen wir nicht mehr
Ist doch egal
Das war mein Fail
Ach komm
Ist er down?
Genau, jetzt können wir eins pushen
Oh man, warum geht da keiner mit?
Sag doch, hinter uns
Nice, predicted
Aber die werden trotzdem ganz schön gerekt, ne
Lass mal ein Stückchen weg
Wo bist du?
Oh gesleebt, fuck
Na Genji hat mich geschlitzt
Das sind halt richtig sinnlose Plays ey, oh man
Ich werde immer voll übermütig, nachdem ich irgendwie zwei Minuten Gegner rum niedergehämmert hab, weißt du
Dabei müsstest du eigentlich gerade save spielen
Da können die mal warten, bevor die da jetzt wieder einzumunsterben
Ich bin drinnen
Das gibt's nicht
Oh, zusammenreißen
Ich muss halt selber auf hitscan gehen, der Genji
Oh wir haben jetzt einen Tracer gekriegt
Wo sind die Leute?
Oh die liegen, die liegen, die liegen
Ich hatte so viel Spaß als Hanzo
Hanzo, du hast doch gut gewonnen
Out Hanzo
Nein nein ich lass dich hier nicht rumschieben
Die D.Va ist wieder am Start
Fuck gesleebt
Und geschlitzt
Ich nehm mal ne D.Va jetzt, irgendwas wo ich schneller vorkomme
Also ein bisschen Zeit haben wir noch
Ran ran ran
Oh die Fahrrad, die Fahrrad ist fast down
Nein
Das war mit mal ein Fehler
Merci, Merci, Merci
Ey die Tracer muss was machen, die killt halt gar nix
Ana, Ana, Ana auch nicht so low
Ich hab gleich Ulti, wenn wir das noch ein bisschen gestalt kriegen
Nein, du wird ja
Ich hab zweimal den Shatter übelst übermütig verschenkt, das hättest du gesaved
Also das war auf jeden Fall mit meinem Fail
Klar, es war mit Sicherheit nicht nur mein Fail
Ja es war definitiv auch mit meinem Fail
Total übermütig zweimal geshattert weil ich mir gedacht hab ey komm scheiß drauf wir haben das eh locker im Sack
Einfach Yolo Shatter
Aber man muss doch sagen das ist halt auch wieder Overtime, ne
Overtime Krebs
Zehn Minuten Overtime, so eigentlich wie die Zeit gut ist
Genau, das wollte ich grad sagen, das hab ich die Idee auch schon ein paar mal gelesen
Man könnte sagen so ein Kompromisse nach dem Motto, Hälfte der Overtime kriegst du gut geschrieben oder so
Aber eigentlich wäre sogar die ganze angebracht, weil ich mein die haben die Gegner ja auch bekommen
Um weiter zu spielen weißt du
Warum sollst du wenn du klar durch push mit einer Minute übrig oder sagen wir eineinhalb Minuten übrig
Und die Gegner machen in zwei Minuten Overtime push
Warum hast du dann bloß ne
Lass mich meinen das ist Fail, da kriegen sie auch noch mal ne Minute oben drauf am Ende
Wobei, die kriegst du auch oder
Die kriegst du dann auch, diese eine Minute oben drauf von 0 bis 1
Manchmal
Die will mich bestimmt runterkicken
Au
Harambe ist reingesprungen hinter uns irgendwo
Wir sollten runter, ich geh runter zu unserem Harambe
Ich werd hier geregt
Ich bin der einzige hier
Sag mal ich hab gleich
WTF, wo sind die denn
Das war jetzt, ich konnte nicht hinter mich gucken, das war kacke
Ich dachte mir irgendwie ganze Team da, nope
Ok regroup, ordentlich regroup und dann
Einmal wappen
Jetzt ist er wenigstens mal auf Soldier gegangen damit er mal einen Impact hat
Ok Leute Leute Leute Leute nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht verrecken
Kann ich vor, sind wir da
Ok D.Va ist schon drauf
Ist auch schon wieder gelaufen
Ja ich hätte jetzt auch nicht mehr
Das ist doch scheiße
Ok komm regroupen und bashen wir haben 3, wir haben 4 Minuten Zeit danach
Wir haben dann noch 4 Minuten easy
Ja ich heide mich, ich hoffe ich hab mich gefunden
Jetzt werden sie einmal weggeschadet und dann ist es easy wenn
Also ich mach hinter den Hain nun
Ich geh mit Hicron unsere Leute
Och Leute
Ok ok
Ok ich geh jetzt drauf ich geh jetzt drauf
Liegen liegen
TF
Kriegen wir das
Alter der ging ab
Gandalf ist
Was ist Gandalf
Wie heißt er
Gandalf ist
Ok
Meinst du die erwarten jetzt bestchen
Bestimmt
Probier mal Winston oder so die werden auf dem Allgrund rumkämpfen ist jetzt schon
Ja
Also zumindest mal kurz gucken ob die auf den Gebäuden runterziehen
Max hat gechockt ins Clem ja das stimmt
Ich hätte nicht zweimal ich war total übermütig
Ich hab zweimal meinen Shatter auf den Gegner geklatscht weil ich mir gedacht habe
Ach komm easy win easy win
Ach Mensch das tiltet mich
Aber nicht weil jetzt irgendwie jetzt durchgebusht haben oder sowas sondern wegen der Overdrive
Nur deswegen
Ich finde das ist halt auch nicht kompetitiv sowas
Da wird der Blizzard jetzt sagen das ist das ist aber spannender und interessanter zuzuschauen
Wobei man sich da drüber streiten kann
Ich weiß nicht also ab einem gewissen Punkt sollte einfach Stopp sein
Zehn Sekunden Over Time ok
Danach Finish aus
Man könnte ja auch so eine Kompromisse machen so nach dem Motto
Solange mehr Leute am Kart stehen
Dann gewinnen die Defender oder was weiß ich sowas
Weißte kannst du ja machen
Oben ist ein Hanzo
Nix da
Da steht ein Bastion
Bastion
Obation
Und ein Hanzo
Echt jetzt
Mach doch mal einer dran so kaputt
Ich pushe, ich push durch
Anna, Anna, Anna, Anna, Anna
Ich musste weg
Ich hab ein Schild, ich hab ein Schild gesetzt
Ich hab gleich Ulti
Hallo Mr. Tommy
MxR
Ich bleib mal auf dem Kart
Das Winter Event ist live ok das heißt wenn wir stoppen
Dann müssen wir Patch ziehen
Sollten wir das auch machen sonst spielen wir quasi mit kaum Leuten
Ich gehe gleich High Ground
Eine krasse Winston
Nice, nice
Jetzt regroupen, regroupen und durchpushen
Wir brauchen ja nicht mal lang
Bin gleich da
Nice, nice, nice, nice
Ab gehts
Ich bin oben drauf
Winston oben mit Mercy
Mach den tot
Ich bin auf der Fahrer über euch
Ich bin auf der Mercy hinten
Die Mercy was ist das
Jetzt ist aber clear hier
What the fuck
Patch ist wirklich live
Das war nice
Objektive Time
35% ey
Anjo
Wir bleiben mal drin und gucken wie viel es gab jetzt
Wir haben Krillax
Gegnerteam
Das Match hat viel zu lange gedauert das hat ja alles reingepasst
Eine Minute 48 fehlt
Die Preparation Time auch noch
30 oder so
Ich habe es jetzt zwei extra angeguckt aber nicht dem Moment rüber auf einen anderen Bildschirm geschaut
30 oder so glaube ich
Wir machen Pause ich futter mal was
Wir laden jetzt mal Patch
Patch laden
Zehn Minuten das wäre perfekt
Wir machen kurz was essen
Wir machen kurz Pause ich erst auch was
Jetzt installiert das
Bis gleich
Ich hole mir jetzt auch was bin gleich wieder am Start
60mb Patch ja schon alles vorgeladen
In queue 4000 players ahead of you perfekt
Gucken wir uns jetzt die queue an das ist wunderbar
Sitzen wir jetzt mal zusammen in der queue
So ich hole mir auch mal kurz was zu futtern
So ich hole mal kurz was zu futtern